my parents your parents they got to play
defense
they got to just try to keep Playboys
out of the house
right they got to keep try to keep like
uh HBO out of the house
those days are long gone they're over
and so I don't allow my kids to have
phones and I know I'm way in the
minority on that and I'm a hundred
percent confident not even a shadow of a
doubt in my life that the Arc of
um the next 10 to 15 years that I'll be
proven correct on that deal but I just
don't allow it
um and then when your kids get older and
you decide to hand them a phone you have
to know I'm handing them over
to every Playboy ever in the human
history is right on their phone every
pornography app every video ever
recorded is on that phone
and
please don't make videos of your own
please don't ask people for photos of
your own because now you're trafficking
child support so I think you have those
conversations very very directly